there are certain castor calls in
eSports that have passed into legend
even though I only have a bat on the
floor I think is that the bet opaque or
maybe a trouble you're dead Bart tries
to clean it up for real oh look at a
glass look at the bows thank you why was
that
here he comes once again the first base
is a trend he's gonna hit the ground
there's cold they're all together PPT
here comes the ice blah serenity
[Applause]
and while all of those are hype as hell
and inseparably tied to the events they
described there's only one that actually
changed the course of history
surely you can't be serious now if
you're not a dota player and you don't
know [ __ ] about the Philippines you
might think laqad mata tug sounds like a
certain phrase from The Lion King
una muchacha and in some ways the two
are very similar but before we get into
that here's a little bit of context
laqad mata tog derives from Tagalog one
of the official languages of the
Philippines and if there are three
things you should know about the
Philippines it's that the people there
love Manny Pacquiao they take life very
seriously and above all else
they're crazy about dota 2 not only have
Filipino teams been involved in some of
the game's most iconic moments
but their fans are among eSports the
most passionate anyway the story of
laqad mata tog begins back at the ESL
one Katowice in 2018 during the group
stage best of three between fnatic and
team secret the series is tied 1-1 but
in game 3 things weren't looking great
for fnatic and blinking inside the base
he gets beat out can plumpie hold him in
here
he's got Swamp available and he'll swap
him out and the tornado no return ticket
punched by a title Envy is that he'll be
punched down by every single member of
team secrets despite facing would appear
to be certain defeat fnatic refused to
give up and blindside of their opponents
with a hail-mary backdoor play goodbye
light died and goodbye eternal enemy two
minutes on the sidelines universe he's
going in he's going for the gg ito the
back of the range creep up here as well
but especially doing this going for the
full gg most people watching heard
fogged in kobe-wan casting the play in
English but the Filipino audience they
heard something entirely different
[Music]
if you think that what you just heard
sounds like the product of exhaustion
born delirium you're actually right for
the to Pinoy casters lawn and dunno it
had been a long day 3 a.m. to 4 a.m.
really a bit sleepy but that should have
been the last match I guess for a scope
ass now what the hell does any of that
cast mean well let's break it down laqad
mata tog translates to walk strongly or
walk like a boss normally and refers to
normal basic attacks from the heroes and
all the boys were just an excited
response to how low secrets thrown was
mixed in with the more obscure
references in their cast were classic
lines like which kind of sounds like
valves take on kool-aid lunch box
beverages tapping off the 45 seconds of
non-stop memes was which doesn't really
make any sense but it's probably just
one of those things that feels good to
show I'm Rick James [ __ ] anyway the
clip quickly made waves across the DOTA
community and it brought lawn and you
know into the spotlight Indians were
very known but in the international
scene oh it's like I really you be great
well the phrase became quoted so often
by fans that Valve me chat wheel items
out of each part of the calls dating
them behind the very highest level of Ti
eighths battle paths a few weeks after
its release
you couldn't load into a doe to match
without hearing the familiar cry of
laqad Mata tog
but lon soon discovered that the meme
was inescapable even outside of the game
I was a big day alert
you can see some of the people giggling
like oh these beer gamers or they they
don't really know what that's Gailey by
the time TI 8 rolled around it wasn't
just pub players who were abusing the
chat wheel a number of the teams at the
tournament were too mixed we came in 8th
place
[Music]
this is uncharacteristically sloppy my
VP can't think there's so many chat
wheels all at the same time now earlier
I said that this is the most important
caster call of all time and I stand by
that point because it directly
contributed to one of these meme loving
teams lifting the ages oh gee who
entered TI 8 as the events biggest
underdogs were also its biggest chat
wheel spammers using it an incredible
2038 times throughout the event and of
the 1047 laqad mata togs that were used
no-tail and company were responsible for
305 just topping pain gaming at 291 and
virtus pro at 242 that's right Oh G was
responsible for almost 30 percent of
Alucard Matta togs we heard at EIA but
you might be wondering why at face value
it looked like they were just memeing
during the biggest tournament in esports
something you wouldn't exactly put past
o G's roster but there was also another
theory that their actions were a more
deliberate BM strategy to tilt their
opponents before matches began it's a
good feeling in the game like you can
tell it's also like when they started
screaming I could tell some players they
were getting really upset I did you know
they would they would start playing
worse so obviously I mean that's in the
game and people you know they get tilted
tilt is part of dota
it's always been
while gaining a psychological edge over
your opponent's can be huge in DotA as
it turns out oh gee were spamming the
chat wheel more for themselves when we
play we kind of talk to each other's
right so chat wheel is obviously like
just another tool and it's it's mostly
rusting also to be honest it's not about
making the enemies upset to be honest
it's mostly about lifting our spirits
you know like we just feel really good
when it happens I mean I see a ton of
dying and he's giving them each II would
say all chat I'm smiling I'm laughing
I'm having a good time he's having a
good time everybody's having a good time
dance keep going you know TI notoriously
brings a lot of pressure which is
something oh gee knew all too well and
by repeatedly using the chat wheel they
were able to recreate the experience of
a pub game but just chose to go first
they made themselves feel like they were
playing for fun rather than 11 million
dollars and the ages of Champions you
end up going down
no reason to tip so going back to what I
said earlier laqad Matta tog essentially
meant no worries for og thus making it
very similar to Hakuna Matata no not at
all
anyway that unflappable mindset paired
with some godlike plaese helped og
overcome nearly insurmountable odds
terribly Petey's fallen the ball is up
Thompson please defend Hank there but
very visible you've got a very very low
life piranha the og they can't find the
tiger eggs Narva he's got the grip he's
got the control he's got the kill
Thompson is done but the actors
[Applause]
gee right
Jean Thompson Blixen he gets that over
there fight with the snowball say
they're gonna ban shouts orders will be
refined the iron but they're fully OGD
that's understand for two minutes
they can't Thompson total never do mr.
Lee Anna Anna can you do it here is it
all
[Applause]
oh and as incredible as it is that the
chat wheel helped OG to study their
nerves and achieve an unexpected TI win
there's something else that's truly
special about laqad not a tog it's the
only non-english caster call that's made
a lasting impact on the english-speaking
eSports world think about it all the
caster calls you can think of are
probably in English even the hypest
foreign caster moments you know about
are probably ones where they just scream
an English word
[Applause]
[Applause]
but laqad mata tog has transcended
language barriers dota fans all over the
world now know a Tagalog phrase and have
a decent understanding of what it means
we were not really sure of it what
really made it special is a very genuine
or very authentic when we when we did
that gosh it's because of that kind of
authenticity that people even though
they don't really know together that
much or feel the people in intervention
and imagine the feeling that we really
had badly laqad mata tog represents the
golden standard for what eSports casting
can achieve it brought people into an
amazing moment by giving them a healthy
dose of humor and hype to defining
traits of the DOTA community itself and
if that's not enough to convince you of
laqad marta togs importance even our
Lord and Savior gaben has given it his
seal of approval look at my return to
Canada
I'm so inspired by lawn and do note that
I decided to bring back the greatest
primal rage casting duo of all time
burry the Hackett now before you guys
get too excited Josh couldn't be here
but I do have the next best thing the
berry' board hello Josh how excited are
you to be reunited I'm excited basically
Oh classic Josh answer I miss you
miles Wow I miss you too men you know
what I don't miss I don't miss how you
stole my hosting gig and paid that bill
teehee walk to dart me you sack of we're
still working out the kinks it's a big
chunk of tax and I did it yeah please
chips ahoy mate or a hobnob I already
showed me a bit of hobnob over there I
know I know you'd be wearing a speedo to
the shoot I would have put mine on to
hang in brain eh
[Music]